when you step into pink box donuts it's
like you're stepping into a whimsical
wonderland of treats and sweets they
also have delicious new designs and this
memorial day is extra special here to
tell us more is jessica anderson with
pink box doughnuts and michael johnson
is with amr and medic west welcome you
two thank you for having us great to
have you here jessica what do you guys
have planned for memorial day when it
comes to the special donuts this weekend
we have amazing donuts lined up they
actually launch on thursday but you can
go ahead and get your order in right now
on our website just to get those
pre-orders ready so we have an amazing
lineup of course our american poo is
probably one of our favorite the
american entire lineup yes yes so
buttercream donut with a cake bottom
people love it and we have our classic
american flag we have a memorial ring we
even have a vegan memorial donut sign me
up
so for those on the healthier side you
know you can't go wrong at pink box now
you have something extra special this
weekend that's why michael is here tell
everyone about the new contest that's
going on so we are so excited to be
teaming up with amr and medic quest we
are going to be launching a first
responder design a donut contest so what
this means is that everyone yes everyone
watching right now and you can all go to
our website and submit your ideas for a
first responder inspired donut we're
going to be launching it on memorial day
there's going to be two weeks with that
we can collect all of those ideas we
know everyone has so much creativity out
there so we're so excited to see all of
that and then there will be uh four days
at the end of the month where it will be
open to the public to vote on those top
contests okay i see it okay really
excited about this now michael what does
it mean to you to have pink box team up
with you guys wow it's so exciting to be
partnered with pink box i mean two
organizations that go above and beyond
in the community to make things better
for everyone and
this concept really came from just a
idea to do something unique and
extraordinary for our workforce who've
been working super hard the last couple
of years a lot of barriers a lot of
challenges but they've worked hard we
came up with this idea we pitched it
pink box loved it and immediately went
into production can i try my hand with
you as a judge and you just as a judge
on a first responder donut i have some
props if we have our new uh interns here
have brought some some items for me
thank you very much
i think of like firefighters right so
there's got to be a fire on my donut so
i'll have some flaming hot cheetos on
top flamethrower
hot pink box donut
okay
so there's a fire on top of my donut and
then the first responders they show up
and they have their hoses to put out the
fire so that's why i have these red
vines
on top and they're not sticking but you
see where i'm going with this
you could also you know stick it right
into the donut oh yes see that's why
you're the master of this and then of
course you know then you wanna you wanna
lock everything in the fire is out the
hose put the fire out and you wanna
celebrate a little color yes and that's
why we do the glaze on top of this
i love it if someone's watching they
wanna steal my idea you can have this if
you want i know this could be the winner
it's it's genius i have to say
okay so i see first responder all over
i just created my donut i would submit
it to you guys you put it on the website
everyone would then vote for their
favorite donut correct yeah so the way
this is gonna work we're going to have a
form on our website so be watching our
socials watching the website you can go
on to our website and submit your
concept and then once we pick those top
three content concepts then you can
actually have a chance to win to be in
our lineup in one of our months in 2022.
you tell me this donut if it wins could
actually be featured in a pink box store
here in town it could be pictured yes
michael your honest opinion the
creativity here
fantastic
how many locations are we at now we're
at seven locations we're going to be
opening up our new location outside of
uh las vegas and st george utah this
summer too so we're really excited okay
good one more thing
if you won so say this beautiful donut
yes that's here one i see where you're
going so on top of everything else you
win a free year supply of donuts and a
bunch of cool merch okay so you get to
support pink box you get to be proud you
know have your donut in one of our
months lineups are you going to take a
bite i'm going to i got to drive you
trying to drive my creation
[Laughter]
contest is over here's the winner right
here out of this world thank you guys
very much thank you for joining us
jillian i'm going to eat and send this
over to you